o music est au delà
alors c'est vrai qu'on a tous été
choqués parce qu'on sait tous on
imaginer le pire on s'est dit imaginons
cette personne est et était armé
imaginons que ça sert que les services
de sécurité et réagir un petit peu plus
tard et c'est vrai qu'on se pose des
questions parce qu'en ce moment on a vu
il est inventif ce week-end francis
lalanne
on va en parler en parler agressé une
équipe de journalistes
ce soir c'est le président de la
république qui fait agresser dans la
foule
c'est vrai que on va après ce qui s'est
passé vers 13h15 donc le président était
remonté dans sa voiture après avoir
visité un lycée il est ressorti car des
badauds l'appeler il est allé à leur
rencontre et c'est là que l'incident
s'est produit l'homme a crié montjoie
saint denis à bas la mode chronique
plusieurs responsables politiques ont
souligné qu'il s'agissait d'une
référence un cri de guerre royal estime
auquel a été ajouté une phrase sur
emmanuel macron elle peut notamment être
entendu dans le film les visiteurs
alors on va réagir là-dessus henri
guaino
quand vous avez vu ces images vous avez
été très proche de la sarkozie est ce
que ce que serait plus arrivé depuis que
la symphonie ça peut arriver avec tout
le monde on vit un moment est ce que les
présidents maintenant on va encore aller
au contact
alors d'abord ça peut arriver ça a
toujours pu arriver mais ça ne doit pas
arriver
c'est facile de bien sûr de dire ça mais
dans l'histoire présidente toujours été
en danger en fin dé tous les chefs
d'état en france il ya eu bien sûr ne
sont exacts 2 président assassiné sous
la troisième république
mais beaucoup d'attentats consul général
de gaulle et un président auquel il est
arrivé à peu près la même chose ce cas
car emmanuel macron aps c président
emile loubet à la fin du 19e siècle de
mémoire vers 1880 pascal war mais c'est
vrai que mais c'est très intéressant
parce que vous allez voir c'est ça se
passait pendant l' affaire dreyfus
d'accord il était considéré on le
considérait comme un de refuser en
partisan de dreyfus et de sa
réhabilitation et des antidreyfusards
manifesté lors d'une grande réunion
hippique que le président de la
république présidée et alan ces
manifestants montés jusqu'à la tribune
officielle
et a donné un grand coup de canne sur le
chapeau du président que présente la
troisième fille qui n'avait pratiquement
pas de pouvoir mais il symbolisait il
incarnait la république la nation les
institutions ça a fait un scandale
épouvantable mais vous savez la commune
de thann et de prison a été condamné
monsieur qui avait donné un grand coup
de canne sur la tête ce chapeau en
l'occurrence qui l'avait en forme du
président de la clé dix ans dix ans dix
ans ferme là justement on va en parler
de ça aussi mais c'est pour dire que le
disque le discours attend le discours
sur long ça aurait pu être grave
heureusement ça n'est qu'une gifle mais
n'est pas un discours de nice et c'est
un discours qui ne me qui ne n'est pas à
la hauteur de la gravité de cet acte
alors justement rigolo ggg la réaction
du président de la république emmanuel
macron g8 qui a tenu à relativiser les
choses puisqu'il a dit tout va bien il
faut relativiser cet incident qui est je
pense un fait isolé
il ne faut pas que cela devienne
occulter le reste des sujets si
important que concerne la vie de
beaucoup il faut respecter les fonctions
dans la république et je ne lâcherai
jamais ce combat et fonctions quelles
qu'elles soient sont plus grandes que
nous et ne doivent pas faire l'objet
d'agressions particulière donc on voit
qu emmanuel macron et c'est un voile à
calmer le jeu est divisé les choses de
relativiser les choses justes et risque
quoi risque trois ans de prison et 45000
euros et qui plongera pas sa peine au
choc c'est relativement peu non c'est la
présidence porte plainte oui est ce que
vous pensez comme les nains non la
présidente n'a pas porté plainte en
avoir rien ah ouais ok qu est ce que
vous êtes pour que la présidence porte
plainte justement vous qui le verrait
obligé je pense que le préfet va porter
plainte
c'est un violent sur brit air de
l'autorité publique pour moi c'est très
grave donc oui fauqué plainte pour
mettre un terme à cette escalade
possible de la violence aux rigolos on
le voit vous c'est ce que vous mais il
faut d'abord très intéressant d'avoir la
réaction du président de la république
mais franchement je vous en tant que
citoyen je manque dans ce cas présent je
m'en fiche
julien la fonction n'appartient pas
celui qu'il occupe et là c'est la
fonction qui a été qui a été attaquée
c'est une violence symbolique mais
terrible pour une société
alors on peut dire ça n'est qu'une gifle
non ça n'est pas qu'une jeep c'est ça
que ça veut dire
ça veut dire qu'on a franchi une limite
la limite ultime c'est à dire que
maintenant il n'y a plus deux il n'y a
plus aucune limite à l'agression contre
l'autorité plus aucune chasse et à caen
il ya plus sacré c'est la violence
symbolique là elle est terrible pour la
société toute entière dans les
institutions pour le pays voilà c'est
pas et le fait qu'ils n'étaient que
gifle et qu' ils soient pas blessés que
lui-même c'est le geste voilà c'est fait
ce geste livre c'est une transgression
kiki terrible encore une fois pour la
société il ya plus d'ordre social c'est
le président de la république et
l'autorité de toutes les autorités et
qui est là pour ça un mandat du mandat
du peuple à rien c'est une élection au
suffrage universel et il incarne le pays
paye soula sous la monarchie comme canto
faisait une petite entaille au roi ça a
été le cas de damien dernier régicide
des anciens régimes qui avait entaillé
un peu le bleu le bras 2015 il a été
roué en place publique écartelé mais pas
du tout pas voilà parce que on
atteignait ont porté atteinte aux
symboles de l'autorité à ce sur quoi
repose et la société le jour où on a
commencé à emprisonner le roi louis saez
la non seulement la monarchie disparue
mais la société snel qualité s'est
effondré et il a fallu transférer la
souveraineté sur autre chose donc là on
va c'est très grave ce qui s'est passé
c'est pas du tout secondaire on va
revoir justement ce qui s'est passé sous
un autre angle pas ce qu'est une
personne qui acquiert et filmé sur le
temps et c'est vrai que c'est je trouve
ça assez violent parce que même le bruit
il assez violent et on voit voilà ça
sera très très vite mais regardez
[Musique]
mais n'importe quoi n'importe quoi wes
alors il ya une question claire plein de
questions confiance est plus violent là
encore alors jérôme rodriguez vous j'ai
vu que vous aviez condamné le geste de
francis lalanne concernant les
journalistes de quotidiens ses coudes et
avait condamné juliette
qu'est-ce que vous est-ce que vous
condamnez ce geste de cette personne on
dit que je les fais dès cet après midi
via ma page facebook mais ne pas excuser
de ne pas cautionner ce geste de
peut-être l'expliqué tout simplement
est-ce que ça s'est jamais excusé est-ce
que ça s'explique à s'explique par le
phénomène de violence que nous
subissions depuis pas mal d'années un
truc en france et plus précisément
depuis deux ans je peux comprendre à un
moment donné du moins entendre
l'exaspération de certaines personnes et
qui en viennent à des gestes violents
aujourd'hui j'entends monsieur guaino
sur la symbolique du président de la
république je l'entends moi j'ai plus
l'impression que c'est l'homme qui se
fait gifler et non pas le président de
la république non mais c est qu en est
il aujourd'hui de l'aéro invalides je
fais juste majeur à son alignement gens
ne peut pas dissocier l'homme de ces le
président de la république je suis
d'accord maintenant qu en est il du
symbole de la république de gens qui
manifestent dans une démocratie et qui
eux perdre leur oeil
je n'ai pas vu toute l'assemblée
nationale se lever donc quelle qu'elles
sont les symboles
moi même je suis apparemment un symbole
des mutilés des gilets jaunes qu'est ce
que ça veut dire symbole qu'est ce qu'on
en fait de ce symbole en tout cas
aujourd'hui je répète je ne cautionne
pas je n'excuse pas cherchons à
comprendre quel est le malaise
aujourd'hui pour qu'on arrive à tant de
violence que ce soit de la partie des
politiques du gouvernement en place ou
même de l'ensemble des citoyens
aujourd'hui
vous savez dans un système capitaliste
on ma toujours expliqué qu'une équipe
est à l'image de son responsable
aujourd'hui notre responsable c'est
emmanuel macron en france il a été élu
pour ça
oui on est peut-être à l'image de notre
président c'est à dire violent alors on
va on va parler dans deux minutes avec
macao qui va nous dire aussi ce qu'il
pense à un haut niveau
la sécurité au
vos livres vous est-ce que vous
condamnez se laisse moi j'ai deux
certitudes en fait cyril s'extrait
jamais l'apologie de la haine et de la
violence ne serait ce que pour ma fille
c'est bien et pour l'éducation de ma
fille nsa des jacinthes nan je pense que
l'acte qu'on a vu aujourd'hui c'est une
réponse à une violence d'état une
violence d'état qui soient fiscales
sociales et aussi dans la rue par les
actes parce que ce gouvernement a fait
parce que le responsable de tout ça
c'est emmanuel magro pirogue au
gouvernement et puis votre gouvernement
on entend partout une montée de la
colère est montée de la haine ça fait
trois ans qu'on le répète écouter un
petit peu les français parce que le jour
où ça va péter
là il sera trop tard ça fait 3 sans
qu'on vous dit mais vous n'avez rien à
faire mal face et vous continuez sur
votre ligne de conduite et vous
continuez vous continuez ce qu'on est en
train d'assister aujourd'hui c'est des
français qui sont à bout de souffle à
bout de tous ils n'en peuvent plus mais
ça et un jour ça finira par yves
ollivier et ça c'est triste on nous a
donné la parole à henri guaino et aux
autres protagonistes au niveau lille et
tu le sais je suis le premier à entendre
tout ce que vous dites ici et je suis le
premier à être d'accord avec vous quand
vous dites qu'il ya des gens qui sont au
bout du rouleau ça c'est vrai qu'il ya
des gens qui n'en peuvent plus mais ça
c'est contre-productif salle et nous
propose est clair c'est contre productif
mais sauf que à un moment donné moi je
veux bien l'entendre sur les différents
médias on tape dessus on cherche une
mais personne et sait il ne serait ce
que peut-être psychologiquement j'en
sais rien je n'ai pas les facultés mais
deux peut-être expliquer ce qui s'est
passé dans la tête de cette personne
pour on en arrivait un geste pareil je
ne savais pas dire cautionner voyez ça
veut pas dire qu'il n'a pas voulu faire
aussi un acte héroïque pour lui
on veut dire passer un sale quart
d'heure je pense que c'est ça moi c'est
ça c'est ça qui me pose plus cette
question au niveau des stocks mondiaux
et macao c'est un buzz c'est mal foutu
ouais macao j'allais juste dire que la
actuellement la vie tout ce qui se passe
les gens ils sont prêts à tout pour
faire le buzz c'est s'apprécie pour les
réseaux mais avant tout j'ai juste une
question pour mieux vivre c'est sa ville
et la dignité
vous êtes chez vous à la maison parce
que les prisons de la république c'est
le père de toute la nation française
c'est comme le papa à moi c'est pas mon
père un bon il représente toute la
france je me sens pas du tout
représentée par monsieur 2010 c'est la
seule année où j'ai arrêté de voter
parce qu'il y avait plus de candidats
qu'ils estiment non adressés c'est
triste d'ailleurs ne plus pouvoir
trouver en 2022 j'espère qu'ils auront
un condiment citoyens bref vous la
connaissez de balayer tout ça parce
qu'en étant pour l'instant de ce qu'est
ce qui est si dense qu'il dessine vous
n'avez personne qui vous convient c'est
au jour d'aujourd'hui il ya quelqu'un
qui est en train de se dessiner
s'appelle alexandre langois et je trouve
ça pourrais tu as un beau parcours parce
qu'un policier qui se présente aux
élections présidentielles moi je trouve
cela pas mal vraiment bien macao
j'ai donc juste un petit exemple vous
êtes chez vous à la maison des parents
j'ai vu tout à l'heure tu parlais par
rapport à ta fille donc tu peux
il ya certaines choses nous les parents
quand on fait des enfants ne sont pas
d'accord ou quoi que ce soit donc tu
permettras ton enfants déportés coups de
baffes loupé ce que j'ai dit c'est bien
ce que j'ai dit au début je ne ferai
jamais l'apologie de la haine et de la
violence et je veux pas que ma fille
soit arrivé là non je suis juste en
train d'essayer de faire comprendre à
tout le monde à tous les gens qui sont
en train de nous regarder que à force de
taper sur la tête des français
malheureusement ça finit par répondre
c'est triste c'est triste il y en a qui
sont à bout qu'on peut facilement y ait
une écoute de ce gouvernement ce
gouvernement se fout complètement de la
population à cette fin il parlait si
bien sûr l'asie fait parler moi je le
sais pas si il ya un seul - de répondre
à tous et si vous avez les urnes si t'es
pas content quoi il faut aller voter
passé comme ça on a des enfants là
restera donne s'il te plaît on vote on
la ferme après n'ont pas de soucis la
france dès demain les enfants qui vont
grandir il voyait comme ça comme cyril
il est là il ya certaines personnes qui
l'aiment ya certaines personnes qui
l'apprécient pas en levant cours de
route on lui donne une claque c'est ta
télé a condamné parce que ce sera bien
je te serai président
j'avais pas l'apologie de la violence
que je te dise je comprend parfois dur
en gros j'ai pas dit qu'ils étaient pour
fait quatre fois que je répète la même
chose tu comprends pas mais j'ai pas dit
qu'ils étaient pour je te dis allez il
faut pas tolérer ces gens des trucs
parce que et persil représente la france
donc c'est il représente la france est
comme si vase ayant donné un coup de
tête à tout s'est passé quelque chose a
condamné ce lundi henri guaino
la symbolique est très très très loin 30
ans et à l'importante est gênante pour
le tout tous les français oui je olive
est juste content qu'on n'a pas entendu
françois êtes député la république en
mars vous avez été apostrophé notamment
par part de deux invités jérôme
rodriguez et au niveau livre qu'est ce
que vous leur répondez quand il dit
quand et alors il n'excuse pas mais il
dit il faut je vais vous expliquer dans
quel état sont les français et c'est la
conséquence de ça alors d'autres d'abord
je voudrais leur dire que je sont pas de
mes ennemis
moi en politique je n'ai que des
adversaires way est jeune il risque et
par le débat nestea rispal le discours
qui peut amener des gens à devenir
violent et y compris sur les réseaux
sociaux mais c'est votre discours d'un
an
laissez moi parler monsieur voulait pas
de souci non mais c'est parce que
j'adore le fait de gifler le président
de la république cjce les la république
et giflé la démocratie on veut conquérir
le pouvoir
on en accepte les règles on se présente
vous avez eu des candidats et mines ont
regagné mutilé remaniant restants est-ce
que c'était moi qui attendait les soins
terminer monsieur bah oui mais après on
pouvait parler sur les opérations
symboliques de nantes il est vrai que
fait ce que pour des moqueries
c'est pas le même et mutilés parce que
ce que je dis assez
il n'y a pas de gloire ni dans un camp
donc dans leurs dons que donc la bombe
je dis simplement que le fait de deux
gifles et le président de la république
à dépositaire le plus aux dépositaires
de l'autorité publique
c'est un vrai symbole c'est le même cas
que moi j'étais maire et que j'avais la
dame qui tenait la banque d'accueil de
la mairie
l'amérique qui se faisait insulter et
qui parfois se faisait menacé et donc
parfois et gt1 directeurs d'organismes
hlm et dont les gardiens été retrouvée
parce qu'il faisait respecter les règles
eh bien je crois qu'on entre dans une
société où on a plus de respect et je
crois que c'est très très grave que me
disait henri guaino c'est très profond
parce qu'en fait cette montée de
violence
c'est ça la vous dites lose it vous dit
il depuis je me rends sur le respect en
vous ne vous dites vous vous dites qu'il
ya deux ans moi je vous dis que ça fait
25 ans que ça manque
j'ai commencé ma carrière en 1995 dans
l'organisme hlm et je vois bien commencé
à tourner et en fait c'est exact c'est
vrai que c'était pas c'était pas
concevable ça c'était pas concevable
pour les passionnés de cheval françois
lancker encore inédits dont j'ai
approché monsieur générale de l'étoile
et ma vie jamais ce sera aux sagas les
plus reculées pourquoi ça serait faire
ce que j'avais vu tout le protocole je
me souviens que moi j'ai voulu prendre
une photo avec lui ne serait-ce que
passer le bras autour du du du président
compris marc fortier comme on a tous
très fiers de faire je me suis pris une
mandale pour le bras de la mère de la
sécurité que je n'ai jamais moral j'en
viens justement là ça la question de au
point de vue sécurisé alliés comme ans
maintenant moi j'apprends que quelques
minutes avant cet individu est vu sur un
rassemblement anti macron avec des
agriculteurs des gens colère des gilets
jaunes et autres citoyens est vrai c'est
vraiment l'être at il fait pour passer
le barrage c'est peut-être une question
que je posais à monsieur michaud quand
moi je vois que sur paris et le samedi
qui peut pas faire cinq mètres sans
finir au gnouf ou avec justement
d'insinuer giroud ou est-ce que ça a
péché comment ça c'est canon je pose la
question comment ce mec a pu passer est
d'autant plus que la preuve en est c'est
que une fois de plus les équipes de
quotidiens interview c'est la classe
en dix ans une heure avant on attend
macron que font les rg à ce moment là
parce que c'est alors macao au niveau de
la sécurité là est ce qu'il ya eu des
failles ou pas du tout c'est vrai
c'était voilà c'était faisable
ça serait arrivé avec n'importe où ja je
suis un petit souci passé
je suis pas contre tous mes anciens
collègues pas celle là vous voyez aller
pour le droit du chef tu vois quand il
voit ta gueule qu'aujourd'hui je touche
le pays tu vois il touche s'il avait un
couteau paillasse et entaillé le chef
le seul souci c'est quoi qu'on travaille
dans la fosse normalement dans la fosse
il doit avoir un autre placé kuti ah oui
c'est servi au cordeau parce que tu as
système une fois au salon de
l'agriculture quoi que ce soit et avec
quelqu'un qui a pris le chef il
atteignit non ah oui pas qu'il a tenue
qui atténue le chef man tu avais fait
appel ici bien sûr et c'est à l'abri
derrière la pub tout cela il avait été
mis plusieurs temps tout ça donc c'était
juste question dans la fosse il devait y
avoir quelqu'un pour d'accord ça ça n'a
pas été fait c'est vrai que là là là
aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron tu pense qu'il va aller
encore au contact comme ça ou qui va
demander à sa sécurité qu'est ce qui se
passe là sur un coup comme ça tu penses
qu emmanuel macron il a gueulé après il
a dit lévesque s'est passé c'est pas
croyable je sais qu'il a toujours eue
l'adrénaline du public c'est pas la
première fois à amiens pendant les
élections tous à l'ombre de venir on
était là les ouvriers ou quoi il voulait
nous métro savons tous à la méla pas eu
peur d'une des parties qu'il a toujours
été meilleur en journée au contact avec
mais ce que tu penses que la sécurité
s'est pris un savon
quand il retourne une deuxième fois la
sécurité tu vois il empêche pas il est
encore devant les méfiances et un truc
12e juste une question à poser à bernard
montiel on dit tous il ya une légende
qui dit que j'étais litis est vrai ou
pas ça va peut-être me quoique brigitte
macron à extrêmement peur pour emmanuel
mâcon mais physiquement elle a peur qui
lui arrive un accident ça cet incident
là ce soir ça lui reparler forcément est
ce que vous pensez qu'elle peut lui dire
vraiment essaye d'éviter maintenant
d'aller trop contact parce que je sais
qu'elle a très peur pour elle non mais
pour lui c'est vrai je crois que c'est
je crois qu'elle lui dit depuis le début
ça mais lui il est très tactile en plus
ils adorent ça et voyait mal malgré cet
incident alors en fait il faut rappeler
quand même qu'il n'était pas prévu qu'il
s'arrête cette place là c'est ça il est
descendu de lui-même parce que les gens
passent à la personne à mon avis
classant derrière c'est de lui même
qu'il est descendu de la voiture et
qu'il est allé face aux gens parce qu'il
aime le contact et qu'il a besoin qu'on
lui reproche seulement à ces cas
l'elysée justement il
bloquez de tous qu'il entend rien là il
y est allé et d'ailleurs tout de suite
après il a continué à saluer des gens
donc quand à madame macron c'est évident
qu'elle n'a pas envie qu'ils
s'approchent trop mais lui il est comme
ça il est tactile
en plus je signale que le monsieur là en
question qui lui a donné une gifle il
lui a tenu le bras il est lui-même
emmanuel macron lui a tendu la main
regarder et voilà et l'autre on a
profité de la montée en puissance il ya
quelques jours de voir un monsieur en
détresse hurler devant un restaurant
sont mécontents sion glacée à mâcon
samak mersen a entendu cet homme là elle
va se faire cracher dans les médias de
la violence qu'il interpellait le
président en personne à 100 personnes ne
sont la montée en puissance j'aurais
envie au respect du dialogue et du débat
pour pouvoir essayer de régler les
situations
ça va mal finir on en est là aujourd'hui
quoi mais à un moment donné reprenait en
conscience parce que il va y avoir du
dégât
jérôme leurs bagages quand on dit que
c'est quand les gens disent qu'est
d'après les premiers éléments de
l'enquète ce serait les deux hommes qui
sont deux qui sont placés en garde à vue
ingres à vitré dans la mouvance gilet
jaune sérieuse érosion mai mais vous
savez qu'on est quand même responsable
aujourd'hui de la disparition des
dinosaures nous gilet jaune appartenait
au moment où quelqu'un n'est pas content
ça c'est un on est forcément gilet jaune
nous sommes devenus aujourd'hui la
poubelle de tous les mésaventures
politiques des uns et des autres alors
qu'ils soient gilet jaune je ne
cautionne pas plus je n'excuse pas plus
quoi qu'il advienne ça reste à prouver
parce qu'ils sont interviewés ils n'ont
pas de gilet jaune
ils ont été vus sur un rassemblement
mais chez les gens là bas étaient
présents fini l'oppresseur je suis
garant de l'intégrité l'image des gilets
jaunes nationaux on y reviendra tout à
l'heure tu remets un moment donné on ne
peut pas tout mettre l'oreille gilet
jaune les gilles est bon mais parce qu
adam construisent olive olivier voudrais
juste posé une question à tout le monde
et à toutes les personnes qui sont sur
ce plateau est ce que quelqu'un se
rappelle ici qu'au début du mouvement
80% de la population et plus et tj vous
vous rappelez pression briquet il est
agile et au nord est qu'ils étaient
français s'est dit un citoyen il a
raison
si jamais le gouvernement oui je vous
assure vent a été sali par les indigènes
et jaune qui n'est pas du tout et
laissait le jaune on l'a dit plus des
bus dont les en été les premiers à le
recevoir sur son plateau
mais je n'ai eu ni moins que la france
est en détresse voilà la classe moyenne
celle qui s'anime péri aujourd'hui c'est
sale et c'est ce qu'on dit plus
l'engrais guaino quand vous entendez et
françoise brié jolivet des gens je le
moins sur les réseaux sociaux
il ya des gens qui de toutes les façons
peut pas discuter de cette personne il
l'a bien cherché
il ya des gens qui sont extrêmement
dures parce qu'ils sont à bout de
souffle mais ils sont à bout de souffle
regarde le nombre de like sur la
publication bfm tv ce sens le nombre de
gens qui se marre henri guaino qu'est ce
que vous dites ça parce que c'est
violent quand même pour venir à se
fournir débat convient d'avoir moi je
suis pas macro nist nous sont les
acronymes voilà je pense que beaucoup de
gens le savent mais en plus je suis d'un
tempérament critique je n'aime pas la
façon dont ils exercent la fonction
présidentielle bon oui enfin le pari que
vous défendez un moment donné il faut
nettoyer les sinois coup de karcher donc
vous êtes gilet jaune alors même le coup
de canon le rapport à mai qu'elle va pas
mieux que celui on va parler de ce que
nicolas sarkozy a dit à 10 ans le jour
vous dire jour moi le jour où elle comme
un gosse qui descendait nettoyer la
voiture de son père john la fête des
pères après une balle perdue parce que
deux bandes s'affrontent déranger tout
bon non c'est ça le karcher gênés en
stock mais c'est ça m'énerve parce que
c'est pas le sujet était pas le sujet on
peut refaire toute histoire lentilles
macro nioro faire tout ça voulait voilà
un désir il faut distinguer ce qu'on
pense de monsieur macron la personne de
monsieur giron de sa politique
la façon dont il se comporte bien ou mal
alors il ya les pea ceux qui sont pour
ceux qui sont contre très bien je je je
vois très bien tout le monde voit très
bien la violence il monte dans la
société
elle monte parce qu'il ya des gens
durant et partielle des causes de cette
violence
très bien sanaa je pense qu'il faut
distinguer absolument si on est un peu
responsable ce qui vient de se passer de
tout ce qui vient d'être dit voilà c'est
je ne veux pas savoir si c'est de la
faute de monsieur macron si c'est la
faute du capitalisme c'est votre jeu la
question qui se pose à chacun d'entre
nous c'est s
ça c'est tolérable de repousser à ce
point les limites il ya plus d'une année
que les années commencent maintenant
après on peut apprendre comment ce genre
de choses posons nous les bonnes
questions après non mais c'est autre
chose
je veux bien je peux pas laisser les
choses en l'état non mais il ya des gens
qui tirait sur le général de gaulle
pendant la guerre d'algérie il y en
avait qui est très bonnes raisons je les
désapprouve
mais voilà on vous a condamné à mort il
va fusiller ça me paraissait tout à fait
tout à fait légitime si vous voulez et
on les appelle au meurtre sur les gilets
jaunes ans qui n'ont pas été condamnés
mais sait on n'est pas sur le problème
des gis les gens d'aujourd'hui on est on
est sur cette symbolique fr.fr une heure
sur les ide et jaune avec vous si vous
aussi vous voulez en cascade match les
logis cette différence de l'ass qui sait
ce qui va le plus mais non parce que
c'est le président de la république en a
beaucoup que ça va on appelait ça dans
la dent dans l'ancien régime
les deux corps du roi donc il ya la
personne
et puis il ya la fonction reconnaissance
fonctionner ce que cette fonction elle
et elle elle représente elle incarne
elle symbolise la france son unité ses
institutions sa démocratie sa liberté
l'époque
après on peut détester le président de
la république mais cette violence
symbolique elle touche toute la société
elle perd sur toute la société comment
vous allez expliquer après un gosse que
c'est passé c'est pas bien de balancer
des cocktails molotov dans la voiture
d'un policier dans le bloc notes en bloc
les producteurs comment vous allez
expliquer ainsi qu'au respect comment
vous allez expliquer attendait un gosse
qui est il et il est scandaleux que le
père vient de gifler ou taper le
professeur de classe parce qu'il n'est
pas compte sur vous ne pouvez plus voilà
c'est ça le problème
alors des solutions c'est pas juste
condamner jérôme et henry c'est juste
prendre la mesure
l'amour et la mesure où ce jeu c'est
dimension et la dimension scénique c'est
la symbolique ça les exemples mon
collègue j'ai l'impression et moi je
veux bien faire une et venaient tous les
débats vous vous êtes sur l'école sur la
manière de soigner la société on sera
peut-être d'accord peut-être pas
d'incidence pour les laisser sur un
autre sujet si on peut laisser mon le
haut niveau quand vous avez vu ça quelle
a été votre première réaction
même avant vraiment ma première réaction
que je trouve ça triste aujourd'hui la
société on arrive là tellement qu'à la
triste vous étiez content dit la vérité
non c'est pas contents alors moi je vais
être honnête avec tout le monde
dans la société française je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de personnes et sont déjà dû
au moins une fois j m amène tape dans la
gueule à celui-là mais il ne faut pas
mais le projet d'ailleurs s'il ne faut
pas le prenais c'est pas bien c'est pour
moi un jeu le monsieur qui lève la main
là aujourd'hui c'est quelqu'un qui à
bout tout simplement commenté mon corps
à ces [ __ ] remo mais on en arrive à
notre démesurée moi je regardais de vous
dire on en arrive à la démesure c'est
pas normal si on arrivait à la dure
genève à chaud mais là je veux bien
entendu je comprends l'exaspération oui
je comprends le ras-le-bol je comprends
ça c'est évidemment s'ils sortent on
sort de signer en plus d'une christian
lair qui matraquent tout le monde bien
sûr qu'on comprend mais malgré tout vous
pouvez pas dire que les mouvements d'un
gilet jaune a été complètement phagocyté
a été détruit par la violence par la
violence des black blocks
en fait vous les légendes aujourd'hui
n'existe plus malheureusement nous avons
entendu parler des black blocs pourquoi
n'entend on pas jamais parler de la
violence du top mais parce que vous
étiez samedi on a voté non je suis
franchement c'est horrible nous allons
tenir avec ont changé mais je vais voter
si jamais je suis pas dur à gérer votre
la victoire de fond ce week-end on va
aller voir des gilet jaune vous allez
voir qu'ils sont pas morts alors j'ai
perdu mon nom me plaindrai sur livre
lives et jérôme je trouve quand même
qu'à une certaine ambiguïté dans votre
avis j'attendais c'est un oui mais vous
en donner
j'attendais vous condamner sans
condamner vous dit peut-être qu'il n'a
cherché où je voudrais secura les ans
avec le zèle de gérer une explication
pour pu que ça ne se reproduise gilles
cds que c'est un big y trouvons une
solution aujourd'hui pour que l'ensemble
des français puissent se sentir bien là
où il n'y jamais en travaillant même si
aucune autre solution mais bien sûr
cette commission durée mais qu'est ce
qu'on fait on en parle on fait on on en
fait un buzz où on essayait après de
trouver des solutions pour plus que ça
ce sont aujourd'hui les cours
d'éducation civique à l'école je pose la
question en termes d'éducation non
j'aimerais j'aimerais écoutez je jolivet
j'aimerais réagir par rapport aux propos
de haut niveau libre si vous permettez
je trouve que vous avez un discours
permissifs monsieur quand vous avez un
discours permissifs d'accord quand vous
commentez et presque incitatif pas bon
et moi je trouve que
la violence qui s'insèrent notre société
on avait d'ailleurs parlé dans le
dernier débat que j'ai fait ici
mais les réseaux sociaux plus
l'hystérisation de la parole plus les
postures les le don de prise de parole
eh bien je pense que ça peut amener des
gens à passer à l'acte et les
instigateurs j'en fait peut-être partie
parfois quand tu réagis à mes adjoints
non mais je suis quelqu'un de modeste
monsieur est très humble parce qu'ils
sont en revanche est savoureuse regardez
vous dans un an en revanche en revanche
quand on est un leader puisque moi je
suis un député parmi d'autres attention
sur les leaders
quand on est un leader au moyen d'un sur
ce plateau eh bien on a en un devoir de
protéger les règles de la république ce
qu'on fait depuis trois ans monsieur
c'est moi je n'ai eu à 500 vous me
connaissez très bien je suis là mais je
me permets de vous répondre parce que
c'est horrible ce que vous venez de dire
si vous connaissiez un peu mieux ça fait
trois ans que j'appelle au calme
trois en trois ans et j'ai jamais fait
le contraire et je ne ferai jamais le
fond des poches en entrée de plateau je
vous ai dit vous avez déjà oublié d'être
peut-être amnésique ça peut-être pas de
votre faute n'en ai dit que je ne ferais
jamais l'un sur l'audi de la haine et de
la violence insulté ses cieux je vous ai
dit aussi que c'était parce que ce
matin' je sais que je vous ai compris
que si ce monsieur si ce monsieur il a
perdu non monsieur qui met la jfp je ne
sais pas saviez j'aimerais bien
d'ailleurs la connaître un petit baissé
de 6,6 me suis là perdu ce gie admis le
juge
sa femme sa famille ses enfants qui
s'amusent et bat malheureusement il en
est arrivé à pété un plomb et bat
malheureusement c'est des choses karim
ben c'est triste c'est triste d'en
arriver là mais c'est à cause de vous
rappelez vous que c'est à cause de vous
et de votre gouvernement est bien sûr
habiter ensemble